So the clowns over at Fox News are just that
absolutely thrilled that we live in a country
where people are free to work multiple jobs
because one job doesn't give them a stable,
a standard of living.
There's this concept called freedom from versus
freedom too that exists in political philosophy
and it relates to positive and negative freedoms.
Okay, so positive liberty is the freedom to
do something and negative liberty is the freedom
from being stopped by other people from doing
something.
So the point is there's different types of
liberty and sometimes the freedom to do something
is actually only relevant because there's
a lack of freedom somewhere else.
So here's an example.
If I say it's great to have the freedom in
the United States to work for whichever company
gives you the best health insurance, a counterpoint
would be, hold on a second.
It's terrible to lack the freedom in the United
States to be able to just work whatever job
is the most rewarding job without being constrained
by worrying about losing your health insurance.
That's the way I would see it.
Okay.
This gets us to Fox News.
Now, if I said to you, if you look at the
numbers of people in the United States who
are working multiple jobs, is that a form
of freedom to work as many jobs as you want?
Or is that actually a reflection of the lack
of freedom that stagnant wages and a lack
of living wages place on people and force
them into having to work multiple jobs?
I consider the working multiple jobs thing,
an indicator of the lack of freedom that too
many workers in the United States experience,
which gets us to the Fox News perspective
on this issue where absolute and total farcical
clowns, Pete Heg, Seth and Ainslie Earhart
are just gushing.
They're literally thanking God about how wonderful
it is that we live in a country where people
can work multiple jobs.
Uh, uh, and it's, it's mind blowing that this
is actually an analysis that resonates with
millions of people in this country.
Take a look.
Yeah.
You know what Kamel Harris says is so, so
disingenuous.
For most of my life, I've worked two or three
or four of jobs
of sources of income.
Okay.
Today, you can do that more flexibly.
How many people do you know who do something
and then maybe in their free time they drive
an Uber or they do something else to bring
in extra cash?
Thank God we live in the kind of country where
we have the innovation and flexibility where
you can bring in money from different places,
do different things.
When I'm in an Uber and you talk to them,
you get to know on many of them do say they're
doing this to make a little extra money and
then we start talking about how much extra
do you monitor fast do you make a week and
it's enough to pay for their kids to take
an extra swim class.
This one guy told me, or it's enough to put
a little bit of money aside for their kids
to go to college.
I love those types of people.
My Dad worked several jobs.
If he had the opportunity to make a little
extra, he would.
These people are truly sick.
These, I mean it's, it's not inspiring that
so many people have to work second jobs and
third jobs.
It would be inspiring to live in a country
where people didn't have to do that.
Right.
This is like those supposedly heartwarming,
inspirational stories about how great Americans
are because when little Jimmy needed a prosthetic
leg because of a medical condition, Jimmy's
classmates and teachers came together to fundraise
and do bake sales to raise money.
What a great country.
No, no.
It's disgusting that one of the richest countries
in the world makes the reality one where Jimmy
couldn't just get the prosthetic leg and needed
money from his classmates and from teachers
and from the parents of classmates buying
muffins at a bake sale.
It's backwards.
Okay, and I actually want to go further.
This multiple job status quo that's so common
actually reinforces the system we have, I've
talked about this in my segments about types
of activism that go beyond just signing a
petition or calling your elected official.
I've said before, corporations have huge disproportionate
control over our systems, the legal system,
the judicial system, media, everything.
They maintain control in part by making sure
that there's a system in which the average
person doesn't go protest, doesn't demand
change, doesn't participate in strategic defaults
or mass rallies in urban centers.
And one of the best ways to make sure people
don't do that, that people don't protest and
people don't demand change is if they can't
even miss a day of work because that would
be two or three jobs that they might get fired
from or they can't miss a day of work because
they can't buy food if they miss that day
of work.
That's a really great way to make sure people
don't show up and actually protest and demand
real change.
And if you're in a situation where you even
need multiple jobs, then you are very unlikely
to have the wherewithal and resources to go
and protest and demand changes to the system
that caused you to need two or three jobs
in the first place.
This is a self reinforcing feedback loop and
I mean, listen, I don't know the Fox News
hosts who said it's just so inspiring to live
in a country.
Thank God we in a country where people can
work 10 jobs if that's what they want to do,
they may be useful idiots.
They may be a actual cogs in the wheel deliberately
reinforcing the system.
It doesn't really matter.
Okay.
The effect is that they are reinforcing the
system that big corporations have already
done a pretty damn good job at reinforcing
really disturbing and disgusting stuff.